[Musique]
les intervenants de l'accord
m
oui enfin enfin oui oui et puis même de
les voir eux parce que c'est vrai que
pour discuter déjà pour échanger nous en
histoire géographie ont fait pas mal de
débats ont fait pas mal des changes donc
c'est vrai que quand on a nos élèves
avec le masque c'est pas toujours
évident d'une part et puis quand il
papote aussi un petit peu entre eux ça
permet de voir qui maintenant va pouvoir
papoter maintenant donc pas tant ça
c'est bien aussi et puis c'est agréable
de les voir enfin je vois déjà y en a
qui sourit la qui viennent d'arriver à
temps et que quand on est rentré en bts
qu'on avait déjà l'obligation de mettre
le masque sachant que le pen on n'avait
jamais vu les profs sur les masques donc
là c'est la première fois que notre
d'aujourd'hui avec un simple masque ça
fait super bizarre